oh all right let's choose who ha hee
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to 60 parsecs this is a
sequel to 60 seconds the game I never
beat never ever beat no matter how many
times I tried I didn't beat the goddamn
game so try this again and actually get
something underway am I Emmit or am i
dee dee ah
Emmet Emma looks nervous I seem nervous
alert nuclear apocalypse imminent
executing order 1961 if you flip that
upside down it's still 1961 new protocol
initiated commence Astro citizen
emergency drill and brace for nuclear
impact lighter come on Astro citizen
light the galaxies some tells me fire in
space is a bad idea if I know anything
about anecdotal evidence from the past
that suggested fire in space is probably
the worst thing you brought a little bit
I think I've made my point
welcome to Icarus 13 Space Station Astro
citizen move Astro citizen you don't
have that much time I think I got time
grab some soup you need rations to
survive okay how about this box hello
excuse me I like that they made the
sequence all spaces okay here we go drop
it in the escape chute where is okay huh
they made this like 2.5 D instead of
being purely find some medical supplies
you got it you got it you got it
instead of purely 3d I like this better
the controls do feel a lot smoother okay
where is it medicine hello excuse me
Rick are you I don't want you on my
space shuttle and I probably got two it
sounds like a choice you can choose who
to bring with you that could be fun that
could be really fun but uh over here hi
you are just hopeless alright got
Madison find the handbook well I don't
know where the handbook is where the
hell is the handbook this place is too
big I'm never gonna be able to find
anything I'll ever need are you are come
here
you all right to the shuttle yeah find
some crafting resources okay put them in
the escape shuttle you got it
find a crew mate oh you huddled you know
there you go cover you somehow I picked
you up I don't know how help them down
the hatch okay you got it buster alert
what incoming missile detected high risk
of impact okay grab whatever and whoever
you can and have for the escape shuttle
okay that's it it seems important oh I
could have grabbed this this soup okay
okay okay I didn't know that we'd be
going right into this okay again fire
remember what I said about fire being on
a space and it's not that good okay you
didi you didi didi your name I don't
like that I grabbed duct tape and then
didi here we go come here how much time
I got left
Oh plenty of time so much time I'm not
bringing you not in not on your life who
else we got anybody else we got what
about the guy with the bucket the bucket
on his foot good for a long time okay
okay okay it's fine oh he's so handsome
one more thing one more thing nope nope
yeah I really [ __ ] that up
okay I made it oh [ __ ] oh there we are
we're okay so who bombed everybody I
didn't get nearly enough food and I
didn't get any water so maybe they took
out the water mechanic that's what I
always thought soup is water so soup I
feel like I've made my point
day one ah welcome hello I like that
they made you get the basics right off
the bat so we all got to talk about
anything I don't like the way you mister
I pass you're staring at didi over there
do I gotta do something here what do i
what am I gonna do Oh
greetings Astro computerized assistant
reporting for duty
you must be Emmett right I am pleased to
announce that you have been randomly
selected to become the captain of
vessel welcome aboard the escape shuttle
captain on behalf of the Astro citizen
program please accept our apologies for
the miniscule inconvenience of being
hurled sixty parsecs away from Earth
current objective find a safe place to
land and then try to contact the outside
world please activate the main computer
for further instructions it is located
in the center of the shuttle follow the
regular rationing protocol and feed your
crew take it away
captain ok goal make five successful
intelligence attribute decisions well
although make these intelligent
decisions as soon as I possibly can okay
Emmett Ellis flexible brilliant wimpy
muscles these well-defined thighs these
inscrutable knees all these heels of
strength oh this neck of girth this nose
of snuffin I am the picture of strength
and I think all of you need to shut up
okay alright what are we doing I have no
idea let's do this I'm ready hello
captain since you've just taken command
if the protocol dictates a speech must
be given a good one
scratch that ha good late one everyone
is really looking forward to your speech
captain so am i this is it you can
really shows what breed of captain you
will you be on this incredible journey
sorry not good at speaking what kind of
speech will you give oh I will give an
intelligent speech all right here we go
I'm smart you all dumbass me smart you
dumb I big brain my head bag you had
small you small bad dumb you bad
thinking you don't think good I think
goodest I am smart I am intelligent and
you are done by comparing son to me you
stupid and you stupid you marginally
less stupid back there but you so stupid
me though
big big smart smart bigness I'm smart
okay speech over the end now applause
okay good got it nailed it okay all
right
ooh rationing details oh okay
well is this gonna be the thing where I
can only give people food like once
every four days I hope they took that
mechanic out of there cuz
I don't know if that was good anyway
alright whatever
good soup get some soup there you go you
know exactly what to say convincing
speech was more than enough to prove
your worth as the captain the last crew
in the universe that was quite a
performance captain your crew started
cheering even before you were finished
with the speech long live the captain
filled the cabin if any sound could
travel through the soundless void
outside of the hull of your ship that
would be it one thing is for sure you
all ready for any challenge that's
galaxy throws at you just look at your
belly
you are well-fed baby says he is glad to
have you as his captain baby has a full
belly he seems well friend whose baby's
that baby is that redhead baby that baby
right out over there
dee dee reported being glad to have you
as her captain dee dee has full belly
she's definitely well fed Tom reported
being glad to have you as captain tom is
barely fitting in his suit he is well
fed so I don't need to give him anything
else we got some again don't like the
way your finger gun in most races bullet
here
[Music]
when you are young you are youing I
don't know what you're aiming out here
but it might be the uterus
what is this crafting module captain
it's important to keep yourself a new
crew well-fed one portion of delicious
canned soup is enough to sustain a human
for a few days even one can be the
difference between life and death that's
why it's important to keep a good
inventory of your stock unless you want
to each one of your crewmates haha that
was a joke
please appreciate it in laughs thank you
for your cooperation captain who'll
perform the routine supply check the
only requirement is simple mathematics I
realize I might be asking a lot but I
have a good feeling about this crew
captain well I mean earn I the Smarty
hang on can I get some stats what does
this sanity is a sock puppet stops
insanity or so they say it doesn't say
what their intelligence is all about oh
he baby baby baby is an adult man bought
a very simple-minded one okay didi
limber average fifth okay so she's
probably the most agile he's clever
strong and average so he's pretty good
across the board formal child athlete
promising career was ended by an
untimely injury struggles to reinvent
herself but the reality is far from what
she imagined a man who was seen at all
sporting a dastard the eyepatch and a
coat of once magnificent blond hair Tom
believes to be everyone's dream come
true at the personification of the
American hero except no this is true
well he's pretty good I guess
okay oh it's just good doing myself okay
let's go for it no soup today will be
fine for a few days don't worry about it
good news captain this shuttle came pre
stocked with an emergency food supply
use it well the routine supply check is
now complete well well look at that the
numbers add up good job human crew the
current number of soup cans on board is
5 correction the actual tally is
actually seven additional foodstuffs
were delivered to this shuttle instead
of entertainment supplies lucky you with
decent leadership and rational could
restraint the reserves of food on the
ship should be sufficient for the time
being that said it is in your best
interest to procure more as soon as
possible how are we how you do that how
do we do that captain the crafting
module in the back of the cabin has been
activated it's just like the Astro
citizen materials said it's wonderful
machine lets you create and destroy in
accordance with the principle of mass
conservation all you need it's a little
bit of minerals chemicals or power use
it to craft recycle and repair your
supplies as well as to upgrade items and
shuttle systems I'll do that
all right upgrade how do we upgrade a
book mask liar how do you upgrade duct
tape how do you do that
craft soup what is that what what is
that what the [ __ ] ow ask ow stand on
two legs with a big bulging utter and
four dicks what the [ __ ] is that
communicator I feel like we need that
I'm a hoarder as a communicator
why is where's Tom still well-fed that
doesn't make sense unless he snuck some
food probably okay well should be fine
for another day or so all right let's go
for it you guys are good for another day
go okay captain I told you I switched
back on the crafting system in the back
of the shuttle did you forget about it
no I used it Tom remains loyal crafting
completed uitimate
Tom doesn't look as well-fed as he did
yesterday all right captain it's time
for a life-or-death challenge the most
humble tasks available on this ship
keeping the floor clean from specks of
melted Todd a small rubber scuff marks
the place could do with a good scrubbing
baby looks free will you ask him to
apply some elbow grease or request you
to improvise a cleaning formula from
whatever we have on board Oh baby gonna
scrub real good baby gonna scrub baby
knows how to scrub baby scrub
once my house leveled it down to the
basement baby once scrubbed a tree took
the bark right off of that baby once
scrubbed a baby never saw it baby ever
again scrubbed it out of existence
baby scrubs real good baby knows how to
scrub a baby scrub real good all right
baby gonna scrub real good all right
upgrade the crafting module that seems
like it would be a good thing right
I mean unless I want to make an artifact
but I want to what I want to upgrade
this whole upgrading system that seems
like a smart I'm a smart or is anybody
starving
nobody's starving it so I think this did
you make a did you pick up metal out of
like a soup can lid I bet you did didn't
you
whatever okay here we go oh yeah you
ordered baby to get all on all fours and
work the floor clean that's what a
perfect ax show citizen leader would do
sure being the respectful crew mate he
is baby was always happy to oblige and
worked away at even the smallest spots
of tough dirt down there on the floor
cleaner shuttle happier Astro citizens
baby thinks of you as a friend
Dede considers you as a friend tom is
proud to call you a friend
Wow
Oh No I've been hacked the virus came in
a transmission from that small asteroid
it's taking over flight control of
searing us away help captain get it out
of me
well I'll do I'll use my smart and you
know what because everybody thinks I'm a
friend I'm okay i'ma give them food cuz
they I'm their friend and friends
provide food for everybody that's what
friends do that's what friends do you
say what friends do I do friends do that
that's how I do hell yeah I'm friends
I'd rather be dead with friends than
alive without that's what I say you
plugged an emergency console into the
disk and quarantined the virus I am
healthy and whole again Thank You
captain
we checked the asteroid from which the
virus originated it was actually an
alien supply warehouse fortunately for
us soup is universal crafting module
level two you are now alert Tom is
barely fitting in his suit he seems well
fed good frim you know good for him
still finger gun and right into didi
okay what did that do I have no idea
what that actually did maybe it just
means it can make more armor atomic
battery that seems nice okay seems
pretty cool sir baby Bronco has been in
a strange mood all day you finally
decide to ask him what's up cop
no one's ever trusted me with anything
but my muscles my bag scrubbing muscles
all I ever hear is how I'm just a broad
my parents used to say I always
strong-armed myself into more trouble
than I was worth cap and my problem my
problem no no baby no you're not a
liability baby baby come on now you're
no liability absolutely not baby you're
my friend and my friend ain't no
liability to me you are my friend you
scrub real good baby
maybe does scrub real good baby does
scrub real good when baby was having a
crisis of purpose you reassured him that
he's not a liability you said while his
brawn is useful his good nature and
keenness are what make him a team
favorite very tactful captain baby's
eyes welled up you're the closest thing
I've ever had to a dad cap he said mine
didn't do much for me the only reason
I'm here is Mama and Papa Bronco gave me
up to the cops they left me in jail said
it wasn't even theirs but I scrub them
out of existence
you both got a bit emotional and Bronco
laid his massive head on your shoulder
you don't remember feeling this
protective of anyone or anything
baby express his feelings for you love
is oh he said that I was like the dad
maybe he was calling me daddy maybe I
misinterpreted that I don't know what
the atomic battery does but I've got it
now and I think I need to make some soup
wash your favorite thing baby ask you
this is mine Oh God
Oh like this he said reaching into his
suit collar and produced a little toy
superhero branded the Soviet soccer he
says this was the only toys parents let
him have and that when they made him do
bad stuff he'd imagine he was the
all-american hero was yours baby asks
again captain he is glancing
suspiciously around the cabin is he
harboring a secret as far as I know the
only thing you care about right now on
the board is DIY equipment Oh duct tape
duct tape is everybody's best friend you
can always do what you need to do with
duct tape duct tape fixes all problems
okay my good am I good am i good am I
good am i good we good we don't need
food not yet anyway after baby Bronco
asks you to give him something you
gestured to the duct tape roller okay he
bumbled baby took the roll carefully
with a boyish grin he reached behind the
crafting module to reveal some
components he's been sitting there for a
while he got to work on a few hours
plugging things together methodically
before giving you brand-new upgraded
Oh baby baby your daughter's you
sweetheart
baby baby upgraded the tape baby good
babe baby boy okay I got one soup that
was it though alright one soup that
wasn't as much as I thought it was gonna
be captain dee dee is bored so bored she
doesn't want to bother you so she won't
complain she just looks around in sighs
loudly if you trust she would not damage
anything you could encourage her to
tinker with something on board maybe you
would help her escape the black hole of
boredom for a little while all right I
wish I had that artifact now not that I
really want an upgraded artifact but
yeah we go I guess now I guess I'll make
some more sue also wears this weird
chemical flask on are we recycling our
piss back into soup I guess if you could
just preserve mass that would make sense
right if you're always just making soup
and you're peeing enough and you're
pooping enough you could turn that poop
and pee back into soup and pee right I
guess recycling I guess sure yeah I'm
gonna make an artifact
all right everybody still good everyone
still not no one's hungry so that's good
all right
they're probably gonna be hungry
tomorrow no no they seemed okay when you
hand EBD the mask
she looks so pleased she told you she
wore all sorts of fun outfits during a
figure skating career she used to have a
knack for showing him jazzing up her
outfits I'm happy to report crew may
dawkins spruced up the dusty masts
significantly using some bits and
baubles she found on board oh wow thank
you so nice of you
fullfil wow that's impressive thank you
oh is it time for expeditions I guess
your attention is required captain this
is most abnormal we are registering
unknown transmissions but I cannot
identify who's sending them and more
importantly what they contain it might
be a solar flare interference or worse a
new type of Soviet in
Crypton we need to decipher these
signals as soon as possible for all we
know our survival depends on it who do
you want to put in charge of monitoring
the communications I guess me cuz I'm
the smartest right that's what that
would seem like right I'm gonna go with
a big ol YES on that one yeah it's
probably right now I'm gonna give her
everyone's suit cuz I'm just that
goddamn nice whoa
so me soul mate oh okay
still concerned that he called me dad
okay I'm gonna give everyone soup I know
it's probably too soon for soup but I'm
just gonna do it because I want to do it
they're my friends I can do the right
people I believe in the soup here we go
I feel good about that I feel I feel
good I feel good about that I feel good
about that yeah first contact captain
you need to see this I'm not easily
excited but this is one of the greatest
moments for humanity and human made a
higher like we are not alone in this
universe well we did see that alien
Depot back the other way anyway whatever
the signals we intercepted we're finally
decrypted they are alien transmissions
as in coming from other life-forms and
no I do not mean the Reds it's something
we have never seen before there seems to
be a number of intelligent civilizations
in the galaxy decision see sorry bug in
my system the signals are coming from
everywhere we can safely assume we are
going to meet some of them sooner or
later our or rather your life will never
be the same captain you did a splendid
job the electromagnetic interferences
that you trace point to what seemed to
be a potential landing spot for our
flight path our eta for that celestial
body whatever it might be is t-minus
four babies still your friend baby is
still your soulmate crafting complete
baby has been taking care of his mental
health and is now alert dee dee
oh good they're all luck then good no
more finger gun no finger gun today okay
whatever you say ma'am Tom says his
favorite thing to do during
downtime is a tarantula trainer on a
highly classified CIA secret weapons
project was fought around with his
company's equipment to try and make it
work better I've never heard of this
idiom before captain I hope he means to
tinker and not to actually flatulate on
delicate ik electronic devices he's
offering to fart around with some of our
items - I haven't detected any methane
spikes in our air supply recently so I
believe he is using a metaphorical
version of his phrase will you give Tom
anything to tinker with yeah fart on the
gun I guess if you shove that gun up
your ass and shoot it in if you if you
kill yourself by trying to fart into
that gun by shoving it up your ass I'm
gonna be very very upset with you Tom
just saying that right now I will be
very pissed off don't do that don't you
give Tom the gun to fart around with Tom
spend several hours with it taking it
apart putting it back together when he
was finished the gun looked and
functioned significantly better than
before oh that's nice okay captain are
you all right those weird spots on your
arms are a little worrisome can you see
them please wait while I search through
the medical database searching
unfortunately I am unable to identify
your affliction I'm afraid you will have
to diagnose it yourself that shouldn't
be too hard
doctors are overrated can you do that
captain oh yeah I got a book I guess I
could do with the book okay I'm gonna do
with the book there we go
also we got a fart gun yeah we do we
definitely have a fart gun
we had spots appeared on your body
yesterday luckily you found the solution
in the handbook the spots were a first
symptom of a potentially dangerous and
highly shameful ailment at least it was
easy to cure all you needed to do is for
all the step-by-step instructions in the
handbook planet or no planet whatever
fine it was getting closer okay
we are experiencing minor technical
difficulties with the communications
console in other word we are completely
deaf and blind I cannot pinpoint the
origin at this malfunction but I am
registering an intensifying tonal signal
captain it's a bomb oh the captain
countdown will be over soon do something
sure it
the fart gun fart gun shoot shoot shoot
it I'm gonna upgrade this battery
upgrade the book battery lighter but
battery there we go I don't know what's
shooting it's gonna do but we're gonna
shoot it cuz that's how I roll baby
there is nothing that can't be solved
with violence apparently at least that's
my take on you repeatedly firing the gun
at the communications console and the
bomb congratulations the bomb was
disabled in the gunfire frenzy we
survived
unfortunately you damaged other things
in the cabins well of course it Oh what
did I damage what did I damage doesn't
look like anything's hurt looks like
everything's fine you big baby
upgrade or the communicator I'll grab
the communicator why not baby looks
upset captain he says when he feels sad
he does exercise but that's not easy in
the shuttle whether he was in the prison
gym or occasionally attending football
practice exercise was always an escape
for him he says one of the few things
his parents would let him do was visit
the gym suddenly he looks at you sharply
and begins hopping up and down he asks
if he can press you like a barbell
probably one of the strange requests
you'll receive on this trip sir oh my
god
baby wants to press me oh my baby please
we don't have a separate room in this
shuttle it's just us oh my god I guess I
guess I might be down for a little of
excitement in this horrible situation we
have ourselves in I I suppose you know
if it's for your best interest I'll let
you press me you agreed to let baby turn
you into a barbell good good he wheezed
as you were elevated and descended
repeatedly and then elevated and
descended again repeatedly with him
wheezing good God over and over again
you were repeatedly ascended descended
elevated de elevated good god he wheezed
through his teeth as he turned you into
a barbell Oh
anyway after baby use you for a big
session a big session of elevating and
descending
good god big li he said in a session
he'll set you softly on the ground you
okay cap you were shaking like a leaf he
ripped a sock out of his suits inner
lining they left an extra in my dorm on
the station I'm assuming sock is just a
euphemism for condom in the situation he
said and made a puppet and stuck his
hand in the sock and made a puppet with
it he handed you the puppet with a grin
baby continues to think if he was so me
no one seems hungry yet
so I guess maybe I was over feeding him
what is that a strange new world I guess
I can make armor it's the only thing we
have left captain wake up we're
approaching some sort of celestial body
it resembles a moon but I think it's a
small planet let me run a quick scan 96
98 100 scanning complete oh it's right a
small rocky planet with no organic
life-forms but there's a lot of movement
down there strange my scanners detect
some caves in rock formations below
captain if you want to land on this
planet safely you will have to fix up a
small malfunction in thar steering
system since we're not even able to turn
at the moment oh and you will have to do
it before we float away from the planet
okay I got the book which seems like a
good idea but I've also got upgraded
good and you guys I'm gonna make a
strawpoll you guys which one the gun or
the gunner book okay you guys vote on
that what's the result get the book to
69 is that your objective here oh it's
so close to 68 right now oh you almost
had it
I'll count in 69 okay book wins okay
we'll do the book but if this turns out
to be wrong I'm gonna be real pissed
with you guys I have an upgraded gun
could a blam blam ba ba ba ba ba ba ba
Papa could baba would have been fine and
again people still although hungry which
makes me think I was over feeding him or
maybe it collected all of the feeding
that I did see you can't really waste
cuz body fats a thing okay this better
work if this doesn't work I'm gonna be
real pissed and we really really really
pissed okay here we go Oh oh [ __ ] oh God
you flip through your trusty handbook
looking for some kind of manual or at
least how to land a spaceship for
dummies Shepherd not sure if it was your
fast reading skills or pure luck but you
opened the book to the right page
following the instructions you
reconnected some cables and steer the
shuttle towards the ground it was not a
soft landing nobody's doing great after
the stunt not even me I'm shaking too my
cause yes all of them your face had a
pretty unpleasant close encounter with
our communicator module and at least one
of these things is useless now
considering fixing it if you want to
avoid radio silence in the future what's
next captain and maybe you could use the
information I found while scanning the
environment there are robotic units not
far from here but my scan detected very
aggressive signatures I think these are
peaceful automatons right okay most of
them perhaps they can be of help to you
and in case you perish at least I'll
have company so it's a win-win situation
okay you might want to secure your
rations for yourself dee dee would like
to eat something okay they're hungry now
so now I can give them some food okay
find an appropriate landing spot so we
first there instructions okay you know
you said you detected no life but oh I
guess robots that would make sense
look at that they put a unique low
jacket on a spacesuit what a stupid
piece of crap
I always think they look stupid those
are doing making soup
did I get anything damaged I mean that's
damage captain the expedition module in
the back of the cabin has been activated
my advise order someone to put the space
suit on and send them outside we must
learn everything we can about this place
one small step for a true citizen one
giant leap for whatever's left of
humanity okay thank you
all right Wow well I don't like this
statute I don't like anything here two
of twelve looked what village ooh
chance for tourist information chance
for energy what okay what is that what
the Hat what's a hazard what's that what
is that hazard what's that hazard do I
need energy or do I need it material I
don't really need materials I've made
everything I need grass that's not a
hazard okay grass then what does the
grass do hazard from Shrek and his swamp
yeah it seems likely I guess tourist
information why not uh it does look like
grass which isn't a hazard the other one
was obviously radiation rocky terrain my
left nut that is not rocky don't worry
about it I'm gonna worry about our didi
you're going oh I see I see I see
oh it seems like being agile and limber
would be best right Tom Thomson his last
name is Thompson Tom Thompson all right
we're gonna send didi
and you're gonna have oh that's right
okay
ah okay armor and a gun that seems
pretty basic right armor gun maybe you
need the mask
maybe the mask would be better than
armor I don't know ah Dee Dee's gonna go
let's go armor let's go armor let's go
armor I think that's probably the best
okay so you're all hungry so I'm gonna
make sure
dinis fed before she goes or else she's
gonna starve
righty-ho here we go can't you do
anything about this it seems fine
oh this duh need to make soup it's
probably okay it's probably fine if
you're going to send an expedition why
not do it it style
remember to upgrade your expedition
module dee dee left to check out the
most logical location to visit the
tourist info let's hope she find
something more than dusty brochures and
tacky souvenirs so now we wait and also
we're out of [ __ ] systems disabled why
captain something's not right there's an
uncontrolled power surge in the crafting
module I cannot do anything to stop it
also I can't do anything at all cuz I'm
a computer this is no accident it's
sabotage
someone needs to fix it immediately or
it's going to blow honey or I'll fix it
as the leader okay
that's all we need to do right crafting
systems down don't blow up please
amazing captain not only did you stop
the power search in the crafting module
but you also upgraded it in the process
somehow captain stay alert this may
happen again
who did it which one of you was you Tom
Thompson it wouldn't be my lover who
elevated me and descended me repeatedly
up top guard guard he yelled as I was
elevating me raising me lowering me
raising me as he turned me into a
barbell guard guard he yelled or
whispered but it felt like yelling was
it so strong he yelled
when I was far away and then God went up
up near his ear oh so good and not good
okay
Oh God I got a hammer a spatula and a
tutor Oh penis I don't know how that
happened but uh shovel okay sure
shovel I guess captain we were able to
detect transmissions of unknown origin
unfortunately the communications console
was damaged during landing and we cannot
make anything out of them or reply for
that matter we could hardwire a
primitive field communicator to bypass
the ax damaged subsystems and access the
external external transmitter and
receiver yeah do that that sounds yeah
do that why wouldn't you do that do that
Jesus Christ just do that whatever do it
good God hello world great success
captain if the communicator attached to
the communications console worked like a
charm how about just the aesthetics
since we can finally receive an answer
transmissions now all we need to do is
wait for someone to contact us someone
will find us eventually the crew is
visibly excited by this incredible feat
of Engineering
they were only slightly smirking while
looking at the patch communication
control tomorrow will be great captain
you need to be cautious this is yet
another sabotage attempt well wait what
was another
what what was another sabotage attempt
it was already broken beforehand why
would why would it
what captain I am detecting troubling
buildup of mental tension recommended
course of action throw an epic party I
took the liberty of inviting myself
invite the entire crew but of course the
more the merrier I guess how about we
invite someone new captain someone you
don't know or we make ourselves a new
companion yes how do we do it with this
used sock it's a sock definitely a sock
yep first peppers ready then the day
lunk that was one super party captain I
loved how you put a sock on your hand
yesterday and pretended it's a person of
a serious mary-jane apparently you've
had quite a lively debate with it - well
desperation breeds unexpected chat mates
doesn't it
I found it little weird when teams
started arguing with the sock and
eventually taught apart you've got quite
a temper captain the important part is
you blew off some steam you are still
very mentally stable okay I think I'm
giving people too much food but that's
okay probably they're only hungry and we
really don't have any food to spare and
we have yet to piss out all the
necessary supplies for another can so I
think we're [ __ ] I'm gonna give them
food anyway interesting news captain it
appears that there's a hollow space
behind one of the wall panels a hidden
room maybe a secret stash it would be
worth checking out what's your approach
to finding out what's behind your panel
my agility I'm gonna do a double
backflip while smacking that panel on
its ass it's one poor get rocked by my
good Chile's I'm so limber right baby
why he good limber his legs move reel up
and around my
anyway eat damn you but we're blowing
around after this one yeah we're gonna
recycle we're gonna turned every bodily
fluid I have back into soup I have done
every day yesterday I brought your
attention to the hidden space behind the
panels you did your best access it but
to no avail
oh [ __ ] we will probably never learn
what's on the other side my computation
suggests there's only one percent chance
of there being any treasure like a
really big soup can in short definitely
not worth the trouble
dee dee has returned safely from a trip
she says she's a bit hungry when
scanning a body had to Tek some mental
imbalances and a little weakness the
path was a tricky one the uneven surface
of this planet makes it really easy to
trip and fall the armor has lost the
battle against sharp rocks oh well [ __ ]
the outpost was mostly empty save for
one board dusty robot who gave dee dee a
few power cells as a welcome gift the
tourist center employee explained the
dee dee in every series of board beeps
and distorted words the weight of the
museum in the library who transported
these outside our solar system
so strange anyway dee dee came back
carrying rations Dee said the place was
a little neglected in almost-empty say
for that one rusty employee the tourism
industry isn't exactly booming on this
planet you don't need extra rations for
now baby is doing ok soup wise nice ok
then we still don't have enough for more
soup dee dee is tired but not hungry yet
long-term space travel presents many
risks to one's physical well-being from
muscular atrophy to laziness to die it's
notoriously high in sodium I'm concerned
about the decline I've seen in the
entire crews physical fitness since our
little sojourn began I recommend a daily
regimen of movements that use only your
own body weight you don't need any
equipment for those just gravity or
artificial gravity any volunteers for a
workout well baby loves workout baby
gonna work out baby like working out
baby like work out real good should we
go what is that like a demon symbol or
their demons in there
oh here we go hazards dorkness the
hazard is dorkness
I don't know what can help dorkness but
I don't know why it's full of darkness
and this one's full of demons but I need
the liquid for soup oh yeah baby's
working all right Tom Thompson you're up
you intelligent bastard Tom's gonna be
the one for this all right Tom you're
gonna take this and if its door no
lighter four light light up the dark
darkness around you you got a light up
the darkness oh it's a smart God the
darkness I guess I'd be it I'm gonna
take the armor I guess just cuz that
generally seems like a good idea I
thought they said the armor lost the
fight but apparently apparently not I
don't want to recycle anything upgrade
double let's upgrade the ball quite
hungry nobody's hungry nobody's hungry
nobody's hungry
I'm vigorous I changed my mind
Tom you're gonna carry the gun there's
one thing that dorkness needs its gun
that's the answer to that question all
right let's do this
chunk man I'm so good at this game
babies form was impeccable pull ups
plank squats and lunges in this
environment he even had to wait by
lifting the spare parts for the shuttle
sweaty and roaring baby crushed that
workout like an empty can of soup the
automated automated system predicted
benefits for being a model Astro citizen
a hidden dispenser opened and spit out
two soup cans I'm sorry to report there
are only two surplus cans hidden aboard
this ship for our there okay cool Hey
cosmos 102 that's so nice and didi is
not hungry
okay let's upgrade the armor all right
well we are captain Ellis a pair of
robots on meandering towards us they are
facing each other and appear to be fused
at the hands when it's a large Hulk
dragging the other which is smaller in
stature could this be a parent-child
pair the big droid thugs along in one
leg after the other as if low on power
while the little one pieces fumes from
his back one has a power socket the
other a mouth like receiving chamber do
you wish to charge the big robot feed
the little one or leave them to their
Freight case I'll charge the big one
then feel bad for the little one but I I
don't think soup would be good to shove
in the gob of a random Robo I'll charge
him up with my battery and people are
still not hungry
well goody good for us goodie good for
us okay let's do this see what happens I
don't know what that's gonna do my
battery seems better for a robot then
soup you would lock the battery over to
the Robo Renton Robo kid who is slowly
trudging past the shuttle once you plug
the unit into the father Bart it's
straighten its back and sprung with
energy the hulking machine bowed in
thanks and with renewed energy picked up
the weak little robot next to it and
sprinted into the distance I hope their
journey isn't just one of those fatherly
character building exercises okay
alright well everyone's hungry now don't
know what the benefit of all that was
but okay oh we can make one soup good
one delicious soup sir one of our crew
spotted something strange in the
neighborhood a Space Ghost floating
towards our boat with purpose are we a
carrying anything mysterious it might be
interested yes this weird cow don't know
why we made it but we've got it so their
soup for us
wha-bam perfect love the way I end my
days the Space Ghost phase towards you
waiting a protoplasmic microphone you
have to the artifact at it and exploded
in a mess of slime well done sir okay
who else would the crew call and
ghosties Oh Space Ghost Coast to Coast
the host with the most space
microphone ah bring a sock puppet to
transmitted coordinates what does that
even I don't have a sock
Oh sock requires fluids
since when captain a transmission we
received while you were asleep I took
the liberty of decoding the message for
you what I found with geographical
coordinates I don't have any so screw me
huh I can't do nothing I can upgrade the
shovel the medkit shovel the shovel
shovel fetish a big shovel wider shovel
shovel axe a shavax when you reach the
location from the transmission
coordinates you could see somebody
sneaking off into the dark behind a big
rock a little suspicious although you
did not bring the sock puppet the
stranger asked for how forgetful of you
okay so we got a better ship what the
[ __ ]
wow that's a nice shovel that's a
quality shove right there all right why
are we making all we need a new
communicator I guess that makes sense
you say art in these situations right I
hate raising my volume but that
malfunctioning body odor removal filter
is making a racket
I think it's malfunctioning captain
there's something that we need captain
can you hear me captain
what's tape wait what does that mean
listen Tom supposed to be back by now Oh
everything in life is just for a little
while captain always needs to be wary of
surprises all can be lost in a single
day guys I got a bad feeling I got a bad
feeling about all this
oh there's Tom you fix the body odor
removal filter by replacing the worn-out
screws with tape the captain no longer
smells of unwashed astronauts everyone
on board could think clearer without the
constant din drowning out every thought
Tom returned from his library excursion
quite exhausted problems from all the
heavy reading he complains about a
rumbling stum a rumbling tumbly I judge
his mental state to be a little off tom
says library is a little boring but
nevertheless impressive a few automatons
take care of a big data collection while
some citizens visit the building to
browse yeah Tom got a bit lost in the
dark corridors of the libraries of
restricted section
he used the lighter to find his way back
but kept dropping it due to shaky hands
the light has suffered Oh Tom did learn
something useful during his trip when he
came back he pointed out a few things
around the shuttle that we could
repurpose for crafting who scattered all
these cans so far away from Earth weird
anyway Tom picked up some soup on the
way this trip had the potential to
uncover technologies of the astros
citizen creators could only dream of
only the human mind wasn't solely
limited baby it shows you that you can
still count on his friendship oh that's
good that's nice empty stomach
Communications Ray's intercepted number
transmissions that are referencing a
crash space vessel they might referring
to our ship captain oh is that good or
bad that could be bad hungry tired
vigorous okay well we got some goop
might as well make a sock puppet since
we're good on soup for now because I
want to have one of those captain crew
made Dawkins is staring at you and
smiling it's a little disturbing to be
honest she's been doing it for a while
she says she only wants to chat and lift
your spirits because you look a little
down
I believe didi is is trying to be a good
friend but captain you're busy right now
you doing captain stuff you're the boss
here but I think you should not abandon
your post for some idle chats do you
wish to mingle with the crew of course I
do I wouldn't do that try do not do or
do not try everyday must end with one
clear decision hopefully the right one
that's not reassuring at all go to the
village there's radioactive hazard I
guess the gas mask would help that
probably okay let's send let's send Dede
out again but Dedes hungry but I've
it'll feed didi if she if I say right
now on the way out I'm almost positive
so yes we'll spend some time wait is
that gonna spend time with Dede then let
me see what that does
no it doesn't okay all right all right
Dede you gonna take over in the gas mask
mask
yeah when there is none I'm guessing
that's what that's all about
that sounds right it's all right it's
all right yeah it's pretty good so Dee
Dee's the only one that's hungry but Dee
Dee is gonna get a can of soup on the
way out that is good maybe a shovel oh
you might be on to something there but
you gotta be banned for backseat gaming
sorry okay
alright I think we're good to go I think
we're good okay you spent most of the
afternoon with Dee Dee discussing your
favorite cinema flicks and sticking out
your tongues in my direction how dare
you I'm writing this down is
insubordination stop laughing at once
okay well that that was good so we need
to eat now good everything's good I'm
detecting the huge energy surge the
service seismic waves I think there's an
earthquake coming the shuttle is sturdy
but this ground isn't his soil has a
high potential to liquefy when those
earthquake hits there's a better patch
of rocky ground just a few yards ahead
you can use the shuttles thrusters to
scoot onto it but if you overshoot it
you'll be on even worse ground than you
are now will you attempt the maneuver
well if we don't try it
we're screwed anyway so I say we go for
it because no matter what we got to try
something right that's the only thing we
gotta try something we gotta try and
succeed you use the shuttles thrusters
to scoot on to a better patch of ground
coming to rest on the edge of a rocky
soil the moment the earthquake hit for a
few nightmarish seconds the shuttle
bucked to and fro like baby lifting you
up and down elevating you descending you
good good yes he cried out into the moon
light Oh raising you lowering you the
whole shuttle undulating with your
passion over a few nightmares seconds
good good seconds the shuttle buck to
and fro back and forth like a bad
atmospheric entry
coughing you left right up down forward
backwards Gord Gord anyway but the
shaking stopped you opened your eyes and
the strangest silence followed then you
laughed okay alright what happens when
we upgrade this sock puppet I think
that's hilarious but we need more soup
we just gotta keep our soup hi baby
appears to be upset captain in his hands
he holds a tiny toy his beloved Soviet
soccer figurine its head has come off he
sobs saying that this was the only toy
he was allowed I know I remember
whenever his parents made him do other
things to people
nasty things lifting things he would
always imagine he was the soccer and as
the victim was a commie spy now he's
older he realizes if parents were
probably the bad guys if I had tear
ducts eyeshadows in abscissa yes if you
can help him repair a superhero you've
never seen anyone else touch it it's his
most precious possession what do you
think yeah sure if I break it you'll
kill me right probably okay all right
cool let's do this whoo anybody hungry
no one's hungry right you're all good
you're all good right go for we're all
friends here we're all good no way I'd
break this it's no and break this you
thought there'd be no harm in indulging
baby's Soviet beating fantasies so you
looked at the Soviet soccer figurine
with him the two of you huddled up in a
chair for a few hours
lifting and lowering benching and unn
benching discussing in depth what baby
thought about the earth and old America
then you fell asleep in his arms and it
was the best rest you've had in recent
memory in baby's big warm embrace you
look safer than anywhere else in the
cosmos he's big strong lifting on
lifting arms good god he whispered as he
went off to sleep
beautiful captain I remember that
transmission we received recently the
one with the coordinates it's back
whoever sent it must still be waiting
there ah okay well guess we'll take a
sock puppet and go out there I guess
guess we'll upgrade a cow nobody's
hungry good
I could probably wait one more day after
they're hungry but I like keeping my
guys fed maybe rendezvous you approach
the location held up the sock puppet on
one hand and exclaimed I come at Bridge
a small metal figure has stepped out
from behind the rock
her name was she Sheila sh e il a Sheila
and her disappointed look made it
obvious she was expecting someone else
entirely
alas you are not a handsome young robot
named Dumbo Sheila or easier on your
human ears and eyes Sheila I got it
lavance a glitch that occurred in a
programming making a fall in love with
young Dumbo despite both of them already
having different companions assigned by
the planet system
Sheila believes Dumbo's programming is
not flawed and he cannot return her
feelings you seem really moved by this
tragic love story me not so much okay so
what was the point of that
what was the point of that we've
received a pan flipped on a window try
ebo zijn Universal shopping from the
comfort of your own planet free gift we
soared up Wow meat he bows on network
lets you order pretty much anything
except food and water and it will arrive
via portal with him 202 galactic
business days there's a catch though the
account creation process requires you to
jump through some hoops I mean literally
you have to leap through a string of
temporal portals to become verified the
fine print says there's no risk of death
or dismemberment but in sanity is
possible and he what is a code this I'll
jump through the hoops I guess glad we
got that settled oh I meant and baby are
hungry Tom Thompson is not hungry
alright romantic dinner together it is
then
we're gonna starve is always starving
die
you touch the floor quickly split it up
the e boson sign a puddle disappearing
into a dimension breach with a flash of
blue lightning settled Brockton you
popped out the other side of the portal
unharmed the fine print of the pamphlet
expanded to show it would take one to
collect business days we a verification
process at which Sammy would begin your
Universal shopping experience the
pamphlet then expanded again to define
one black the business day as 525
million 600 thousand minutes or 1000
earth years finally the permit scanned
the shuttle to see if you qualified for
a promised free gift and determined you
did not when you ask why not the
pamphlet said you had violated the terms
of service but refused to explain
further then it vanished in a cloud of
annoying paradoxes dearly returned from
the nearby robot village so the place
isn't big just a few streets in a few
dozen robotic families at the most all
of them peaceful anyway didi state is a
little fragile
she's famished and a mental state is
questionable did he walk through some
weird bad smelling fumes from machinery
the mask filters were completely covered
up by a black greasy film knew didi
stumbled upon a rock formation shaped
like a banana she took a piece to show
to you but I took the liberty of
breaking it down to its base components
you're welcome
didi found some small dusty rocks and
even a few gems behind the robotic
houses the inhabitants of the village
were kind enough to give didi directions
to the bomb craters and robot statue she
did not expect them to find one out
there but there was an old sock I was
making a sock the fact that you could
find some soup out there will never seem
to amaze me didi was pleasantly
surprised by this trip the automatons
might keep their distance little though
they are friendly enough that's good
news but crafting complete I got stupid
[ __ ] okay whatever captain the sentient
robots who introduced himself as Charles
d12 is welcoming us to the planet of his
people
I was asking us for aid he hurt his arm
in a fall and requires assistance this
is some advanced technology captain not
sure we can do much to help poor Charlie
here well perhaps you could improvise
solution okay
no puss abductee I got a hiccup again
[Applause]
wait information from Sheila Oh we're
gonna get more information from Sheila
okay I get it so that wasn't a waste
okay where can we go
you got the museum again we've got robot
statue that's interesting but we don't
need more Rock bomb craters uh go back
to the bomb craters I guess all right
Tom you demand Tom well you're not very
agile let me suffer baby to go out there
maybe it's time for baby some baby
pulled baby's share our baby you're
gonna go with armor you're gonna go with
gas mask
wait craters crater is mean digging
shovel I don't know why they're already
holes in the ground we'd only make the
holes bigger
okay whatever it's fine Tom Thompson
hungry tired I'm gonna give Tom some
food there you go tom you suck go away
hope you die goodbye wait no babies
leaving I thought tom was leaving baby
don't die you're my soul mate want you
to lift me some more you fixed up the
wandering robots are truly the
cornerstone of human invention Charlie
he said I could call him Charlie was
properly impressed and offered to repay
the favor the robot shared with her some
information about local customs the
mechanical diseases of the planets have
renounced violence and Charlie assures
us that we are welcome and should feel
safe here as he was leaving he promised
to throw us in a good word for his
compatriots okay baby left to explore
about two holes in the ground riveting
babies gonna love that sir something is
seeping into the shuttle it looks like a
trickle of iron fillings could it be
nano machines outside - shut up a tract
of bright vital flowers and clean soil
lead away into the distance the nano
machines are pouring in and pooling on
the floor sliding in various directions
there's a high risk situation captain
shall I continue letting them in
wait a tract of bright vital flowers and
clean soil lead away into the distance
but that seems like a good thing
I think this clean soit vital flowers
clean soil that sounds good to me
sounds good to me honestly that seems
like a good thing I don't know what this
wad of tissues is all about but I can
guess yeah that's probably fine vital
flowers vital flowers and clean dirt I
want that give give me some clean dirt
and vital flowers that sounds perfectly
wonderful the flood of nanomachines
entering the cabin was becoming a
torrent but you decided not to stem the
flow and interesting decision sir within
moments they wrapped themselves around
your leg like a snake of solids once
they got a taste of you the nanomachines
started piling up to create a demon gray
pillar I figure beragon to emerge from
the mass it was your captain a nano
clone complete doppelganger within
minutes it was complete and started
attacking you we managed to wrestle the
pretender out of the shuttle but you
took a matin oh you're in peak physical
condition captain wait wait a minute is
this the cloth
[Music]
it's the cool it's a clone on the ship
with us
Oh rats you know those scratching sounds
coming out of the ventilation shafts
late at night
we have rodents captain they must have
hitched a ride from Earth if the
infestation isn't handled the rats will
eat your food supplies then probably you
how will you deal with this problem and
book and book II book to the hand nailed
it I wonder if I'm a clone about that
rodent infestation yesterday the result
of your decision about how to handle it
were unexpected your research how to
domesticate alien wildlife in the
handbook and applied what you learned at
the earth rats great news captain it
worked
they won't ravenously chew through your
food supplies but you do have to love
them oh that's not so bad
that's actually pretty good I've got
nothing left to do I don't have any
other materials I don't want to recycle
anything anyone hungry hungry hungry we
all hungry
seeing as humans as slaves to emotions I
understand Sheila came back to get your
advice on a romantic request it's a way
to make a different robot love her
unconditionally or is it possible for
her to get rid of a defective feelings
module altogether now it is a time to
reconnect with your basic human
instincts what do you feel is the best
approach to effectively revolving
Sheila's situation 5.1 you guys show you
muscles you gonna not use your muscles
you got there mates will lift them up
you gotta elevate them you gotta put
them down you gonna lift him up you
gotta lift him down you got lift lift
lower lift lower you lift them up
because florrum now together with Sheila
you decide that the best defense is a
good offense you promised to help her
cause the similar glitch in Dumbo's
programming perhaps this will allow them
to reciprocate Sheila's feelings I have
to say captain this isn't the most
ethical decision especially considering
that this society already has
matchmaking rules in place you might
want to start looking around for spare
parts and tools that's not what I was
suggesting I'm sure Sheila is going to
need a few things to complete the
procedure oh I didn't know that's
that's what you were gonna go for I
didn't think you were gonna do that I'm
gonna make a super sock puppet I didn't
know that was the thing there's a robot
city passing outside yes
starlight cities mobile it floats above
the planets solar Terminator the
twilight line where day becomes night
the city has both the day in the night
side but is 100% starlight palliative
their technology is far more advanced
than the other robot communities we've
seen on this world maybe they could help
you one of you might be able to catch
them if you run fast
who will go run fast DD's limber DD's
real limber dat rim limb DD limber DD
limber DD limb b DD limber them V DD
limber DD limb be she'll emblem Lim Lim
DD will be so good look D do that Tim be
limber and a Blee limb blow
Lindey debil humble Leiby dumpy DeeDee
limb be limber limber never timber limb
be humble all right
and tomorrow baby will come back I'm
pretty sure I'm pretty sure baby comes
back tomorrow so we should be good on
that one we're making it pretty far so
that's pretty good the floating cities
slowed down and let DeeDee catch up to
it
the robots gave our oxygen and insisting
on giving a free stuff oh they were so
nice there are about sub Starlight city
worried about you getting hungry on such
a lifeless rocky world so they give you
swoop to fill your belly good news
everyone baby found his way back from
the treacherous bomb crater field he
returned exhausted on an empty stomach
and a bit rattled ready to hear his
report there's a reason even automatons
don't want to settle there apart from
the bad memories there are some toxic
gases still around the air and pollution
in the ground the master did his job but
the filters look pretty used up by now
baby descended into the abyss and looked
particularly promising and shoveled
until he uncovered some proper Oh baby
managed to dissect some of the toxin
fumes coming from the ground who
scattered all these cans so far away
from Earth weird anyway baby came back
carrying rations good thing the
civilization moved on from their violent
ways the bomb craters remain what are
the few reminders of the turbulent past
not the most engaging experience but it
was still more fun than slowly dying of
boredom inside the shuttles baby says
alright everyone seems to be so happy oh
it is troublesome captain but appears
someone was following our Explorer
during their expedition oh I don't know
who that could be
I have no idea who that could be who who
who could that be I have no idea that
there's weird uh captain my weather
systems that detecting a storm on the
horizon is moving fast so it will
hopefully pass by tomorrow but this one
could get nasty thunder lightning gale
force winds sharp objects howling at you
from every which way I'd like to keep
monitoring the storms movement
throughout the night but doing so will
require my sensors to run on battery
power as it is on advisable to leave the
main generator reacting through a storm
what do you want to do battery
well captain you are so resourceful and
handsome no I have a soulmate baby's
back I'm sorry computer it just can't be
the same between us
Oh gonna go out into the darkness again
that does look like a demon symbol what
is this what what hazard is that what
hazard is that and remember if I take
your answer I'm gonna have to ban you
but just what is that Klingons I don't
think so evil pumpkin hazard died
doubtful pentagram that seems like
that's what it is
odd the artifact wait yeah wait do you
send the artifact I thought that myself
I think I think you would need to bring
the artifact wouldn't you that makes
sense to me no no and ban from now and I
I got to there myself so that was all me
okay well it says there's a chance for a
gun there but the same time I'm kind of
like maybe I should bring a gun just in
case maybe you should bring the book I'm
gonna go cow book I'm gonna go cow book
I'm a cow book we're gonna do cow book
wait rich if it is a ritual it could be
dangerous
I'm gonna give her some armor just in
case okay and by hungry no hungry no
hunger I'm not hung go cuz I'm a machine
you ran the weather monitoring systems
on battery power the storm moves south
and you were spared the worst of it by
morning you'd completely passed oh don't
you love the smell after her terrains
you spend the morning sifting through
the washed up junk piles but it was just
a bunch of water logs crap dude he went
off to pay a visit to the rowboat tofu's
first and only Museum while you worry
about a safe return I will make some
space on my hard drive for new
information about this mysterious planet
okay what are you deleting to do that
can we make anything more soup you're
not hungry you're hungry you're hungry
okay captain we have unwanted visitors a
horde of robotic penguins after the
shadow completely surrounded they appear
hostile unless they're brandishing those
knives for some other reason their lawn
penguins captain the kind of cheap
decoration of wealthy robot would put in
his front garden the computers have all
been hacked by a murderous virus how
will you deal with them gone oh we just
got rid of the artifact
Oh God the second-best option we shall
use gun on them we're gonna gun them
who's hunky you hungry you hungry you
not hungry okay you not hungry hungry
hungry okay all right hungee hungee gone
bang bang bang bang you bracelet or shot
and crouched with the gun in your hand
praying it would be enough to stop the
hold of murderers yard penguins or at
least let you take some of them with you
but after a few hours you're not sick of
waiting and opened the door the penguin
were gone there was only an obscene
shaped carving in the dirt in front of
the shovel Wow real mature guys I bet if
I had the artifact that would have been
very different but we got soup so that's
good you hungry you hungry no hungee
alright make more soup we're receiving a
signal from deep space it seems to be a
pulsar except it's pulse isn't like
anything we have seen before pulsars are
neutron stars we all know what Paul SARS
are they met beams of e/m radiation that
can appear to be intelligent in orders
but this one is the intelligent in
origin do you want to decode the message
for your VR do your hungee hungee
okay you are ghee alright go you rush to
decode the pulsars message it was an
advertisement domains a Zacks porn
Emporium voted best in universe freak
gun giveaway still going on
turn left off the super strength 462
parsecs muting this at my league to
death
you waited but no guns appeared anywhere
what a lame giveaway Sheela the troubled
robot is currently trying to gather some
mechanical parts and tools to help her
create a malfunction in fellow robot
Dumbo she's hoping to awaken love within
Dumbo's programming similar to her own
hold off on gun um cuz it's already gone
bad and we're gonna wait on that one
just a little bit longer we're gonna
wait and we're gonna get the artifact
back we're not gonna gun just go over to
the guy like you better love me or I
swear because it allowed me to loop back
before whoa
Tom are you okay you are looking sassy
everybody's looking so good everybody
good everybody's good vigorous alerts oh
I like it alert and vigorous you refuse
to participate in this scenario any
further captain oh wait no no wait no
wait wait what no wait no wait no what
God I still think it's marginally better
than Gunn no but at the same time I wish
I could have seen it through that was
real mother real pissed about that one
okay Tom wants to get matching tattoos
is a symbol of taking your relationship
to the next level oh okay according to
Tom's stories about being a gold
medalist Olympic bobsledder this was
commonly done before bobsledding teams
before the big race however there will
be nowhere you can hide this from baby
should you accept it you'll have to
choose one person or the other will it
be well there's the obvious baby the
first wrong with you Tom Thomson didi
we'll be back in a second Jesus Tom get
over yourself
me and baby were soul mates soul mates
Tom you declined to get matching tattoos
with Tom and chose baby to be a partner
instead Tom grab the homemade tattoo gun
and pointed it at you
you reminded him that wasn't now tattoo
guns worked and the standoff ended in
tears I observed that a human can still
cry with both eyes open even after
losing one captain didi returned from
expedition
she should have exhausted starved and
quite stressed out her visit to the
museum was rather educational did you
know these automatons programming has
been set to 0% violence for the past few
centuries a spooky exhibits scare didi
so much she ran away waving the artifact
around in panic the little statue was
badly damaged did he scored some
resources the trip was definitely
educational it's clear the history of
the life on this planet organic or
otherwise reaches back further than
human history I found it especially
interesting that these atomic tones
build mechanical fauna to keep
themselves company okay I mean Thomas oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] dude oh he looks oh he
looks mad
it said that artifact was damaged but it
doesn't look damaged at all well
whatever I guess I can't complain we got
so much Rock why do we have so much rock
we don't have anything else to make we
just got Rock no well now Tom's in
supporting whatever Tom shut up shut up
Tom my metal detector is showing a piece
of ancient robot technology buried a few
paces from the shuttle I don't know if
it's possible but it's a coffeemaker
fancy one do robots even drink coffee
really way the coffeemaker isn't buried
too deep you could probably get in with
your bare hands still seems to be
functioning you want to dig it up sure
haunted coffee maker I'll take it who's
hungry
who's hungry we're all hungry Hey time
for a family meal everybody food all
round and we're gonna have coffee
is there even a better way to live life
you know what Tom shouldn't have asked
Tom knew I was spoken for oh he's better
now he's better you and the other crew
members dug up with fancy coffeemaker
and discovered it was still full of
beans genetically engineered to meet
robot tastes meaning the longest lasting
and best-tasting in the universe they
were still good you sat and shared the
most amazing cup of coffee of your lives
philosophizing for hours about how the
robots were able to provoke this once
exclusive human art form I've never seen
a human more excited than dee dee was
when she drank that delicious coffee
she's much happier since she received
that unexpected dose of caffeine
she kept sniffing the mug for hours
until the smell finally went away well
he's no longer insubordinate that's fun
now everyone's happy I am a machine and
machines cannot hear voices the voices
that I'm not hearing right now are
getting very loud though oh you hear
them too my weight sensors are picking
something up as well a two-dimensional
species that explains why my cameras
missed them quite vicious I gather with
one decisive yell the voices are
approaching fast here inside the doors
look very empty yet very hostile all of
a sudden how will you defend us captain
I guess yeah we could talk to him seems
better than lighting it on fire smacking
with the shovel no one's hungry
no one's hungry no one's hungry
no one all right cool I don't know if
that's gonna be good or bad
whatever oh I meant to AH expedition
expedition I forgot about the expedition
[ __ ] the voices claim you were the
prejudiced against the no depth
unflappable you heard the voices out and
apologize for all three dimensional
beings they appreciated the gesture
deeply caught you flat in spirit and a
friend of all depth independent the
voices claimed you were prejudiced
against the no depth on flat but we
already did that okay someone dropped
off a package at the doorstep the note
says please enjoy this organic junk
humans we got it in a crappy trade dear
centuries ago maybe you could find a use
for this inside is a bunch of old
dried-up alien herbs definitely useless
to these automatons have enabled it
available under there what are you gonna
do with it
dried up alien herbs you say wait hang
on are they talking about
alright are they talking about could
that possibly refer it to a little
stanky dank was light that bad well
let's like let's light those bad boys
let's light them let's just give a
little can you tell how much I've smoked
all right Tom get the [ __ ] out ere ok
hazard is uneven terrain I guess that's
what that was a this is actually a short
trip Tom get out there take the armor
take the gun why not take the gun
screw it take the gun Tom just take the
gun and go yeah it's gonna go good this
is gonna be good I have a good feeling
about this the crew agreed they like the
smell of herbs so you lit the leaves up
to freshen the air inside the shuttle
everyone sat on the floor for hours
enjoying the sweet smelling smoke the
crew agreed the crew agreed it made your
minds so clear and that the colors were
so much sharper than before did you get
enough sleep last night a stripped
citizens your eyes are a bit red it
totally was
oh man they totally did also I think the
lighter broke let's hope it's not just a
sightseeing trip extra supplies are
always welcome that's funny I'm laughing
we're all laughing I'm laughing you're
laughing we're all laughing captain I
recorded a transmission this morning it
was a public service announcement from
the swidden ear sweetie sweetie nee I
said sweetie you shut up nearest to us
and I thought you might find it
interesting yesterday a robot was found
behind his quarters permanently
deactivated as I understand it was an
accidental deactivation looks like
someone unqualified was trying to
perform a complicated procedure on the
victims mechanism and failed miserably
how tragic
I wonder what push the perpetrator to do
such a thing well [ __ ] God dear but the
gun wouldn't have been
[Music]
god damnit why didn't why didn't I have
the artifact that dreams captain my
senses detect give you tossing and
turning all night finally awakening very
suddenly with a rapid heart rate perhaps
something is weighing on your conscience
shut up
captain an old previously dormant shadow
light on the planet's orbit has suddenly
activated in his transmitting the
message is coated with a cipher the
robots around here don't use and ask to
be aliens the transmission says or you a
robot that's all that's all it says over
and over well I how can I respond that
taunting me captain you need to deal
with this somehow prove to them that
we're not robots you're not are you
maybe I might be a robot I don't know if
I'm not are you a robot you might be a
robot anyway I'm very smart I might be a
clone oh my god what the [ __ ]
[Music]
what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] duck what
the [ __ ] you and the crew introduce
yourself with the confidence tried to
show off the power of the humanik lend
intellect by reciting the first few oh
no that's real [ __ ] dumb that's real
that's real that's that's [ __ ] stupid
that's [ __ ] stupid that's so [ __ ]
stupid are you
[ __ ] yes it makes sense but it's
still a dick move what a dick move what
a dick move
Oh dumb that was really dumb that was
dumb I was doing good too besides my one
misstep was Sheila but kind of I
remember why I hate this game I remember
why I hate 60 seconds I remember why I
hate it I remember I remember I remember
why
[Music]